hello this is Amy from the Philippines
and my question is thus forever exists
I'm pretty sure a lot of people from my
country would like to know the answer to
this very important question so I hope
you could answer it thank you Amy
does forever exist far as I know it's
really hard to tell
here's the question well I'm just
inferring I'm reading in I'm adding you
say people in your country want to know
is it a is it a question really Amy
about the afterlife I don't know if it
is in the afterlife
I certainly am NOT planning on it I am
not counting on any afterlife and I'll
tell you why I've watched people get old
and they don't generally they don't just
die with all their pet the height of
their powers able to pole-vault the
highest able to do math problems the
quickest able to raise a family with
just the right judgment they don't do
that and then disappear we we humans
fade and I suspect the afterlife is just
hopeful thinking and if it turns out
there is an afterlife cool I'm in I will
do my best I'd like to be able to run as
well as I could when I was say 23 I'd
like to be able to ride a bike as well
as I could when I was 34 and I'd like to
be able to write jokes as well as I
could when I was about 38 and then now I
have all this wisdom I'd like to have
that sprinkled in now I'm all this wise
stuff but as far as we can tell forever
goes on forever there's no reason that
to think that time will end we had a big
bang and people speculate about what
happened before that and you can say
nobody knows that's true but just
intuitively for us time travelers all
going one way
I guess left to right it's like that
there probably is a forever
it's a great question Amy thank you